the number of people in england
estimated to have coveted 19 has dropped
40 in just a week
look at the number of cases over the
past year after spiking
over the winter cases now mirror those
seen
before the pandemic and summer of last
year
a sage report found the vaccine might
fail to prevent
hospital admissions among a very small
number of people particularly
the elderly between december the 8th
when the uk began
its mass vaccination rollout and april
the 10th there were over
50 000 hospital admissions
three and a half thousand of those had
received the first dose
of a covet 19 vaccine
for most of these patients the time
between vaccination
and hospital admission was up to 15 days
where infection occurred before immunity
had developed
the researchers say there is a
possibility that vaccinated
elderly and vulnerable people may have
been exposed to coronavirus after
wrongly assuming
they were immune 526 people with a
positive covert
19 tests were admitted to hospital more
than three weeks
after receiving their first dose
113 died
these cases represent vaccine failure
which occurs when a person contracts a
disease
in spite of being vaccinated against it
but
experts say despite this there is still
a lot of cause
for optimism this is really good news
it's real world data
but the cautionary tale is it does take
about three weeks to get really good
immunity from the first
vaccine jab particularly for the older
population
so people do need to be careful for just
a little time after they've had that
first vaccination
and make sure they get the second job
later all the data
is positive and it's very encouraging
the vaccine rollout is having
a real impact on the virus there are
always
caveats in a pandemic but we can
certainly look forward to the summer
with increasing confidence